bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
fois n'est pas coutume nous vous
parlerons pas des déclarations de bruno
le maire mais bien de celle de jo
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'impôt mondiale la dernière
déclaration de joe biden bonjour estelle
manger olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ses caches le
projet est porté par les etats-unis de
joe biden depuis plusieurs semaines
mettre en place un impôt minimum mondial
sur les bénéfices nets des entreprises
on va s'intéresser à dans cette émission
à cette idée comment peut-elle se
matérialiser est ce une bonne solution
pour venir à bout du dumping fiscal de
certaines entreprises quelles
conséquences peut avoir la mise en place
de cet impôt mondial pour en parler nous
serons en deuxième partie avec nathalie
gens sont enseignants chercheurs à neoma
business school donald trump avait opté
pour une politique et d'allègement
fiscal de 35 % l'impôt sur les sociétés
aux états unis est passé à 21 % sous sa
mandature mais aujourd'hui tout est en
train d'être bousculés à l'arrivée de
joe biden s'ajoute la pandémie qui
oblige de nombreux à l'état à trouver de
nouvelles ressources pour renflouer les
caisses
outre atlantique les états unis semblent
devenir le portugais et le porte
étendard d'une idée qui n'est pourtant
pas nouvelle
instaurer un impôt un minimum mondial
sur les bénéfices des entreprises à
hauteur de 21% tous les détails avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
c'est une vraie révolution fiscale qui
émerge du pays du capitalisme
l'administration byden propose un impôt
minimum mondial sur les sociétés qui
permettrait de cibler les bénéfices de
toutes les multinationales y compris des
gars femme dont on cherchait
désespérément comment réussir à des
taxes et depuis bien longtemps
cela mettrait potentiellement un terme
au dumping fiscal traduisez concurrence
fiscale entre du pays
bye bye les paradis fiscaux dumping
fiscal permet aux grosses entreprises de
trouver la fiscalité la plus
intéressante pour installer leur siège
et rapatrier leur bénéfice
en europe on pense tout de suite à
l'irlande qui accueille facebook apple
et compagnie fini également les
entreprises qui quittent leur propre
pays pour l'herbe plus verte du voisin
et les impôts plus légers bombe hayden
n'a rien inventé
l'idée est sur la table de l'os et des
hauts depuis un moment
même si moto 2 21% proposé par les usa
et bien au dessus des attentes des pays
qui plaidait déjà pour sa mise en place
la france visée un petit 12,5 pour cent
pas étonnant donc que notre pays et
l'allemagne aient apporté leur soutien
au projet grâce à cette proposition
les états unis première puissance
mondiale envoie un message fort
notamment aux pays qui pourraient être
réfractaire à réhausser leur fiscalité
exemplaire au passage le projet de taxe
gafa de bruno le maire et pourrait ainsi
permettre au pays de trouver les moyens
financiers pour sortir de la crise
économique engendrée par le cos vide
quoique nos cet impôt mondial on va
également pénalisé certains pays pauvres
qui ont bien besoin d'une fiscalité
attractive pour booster leurs économies
décidément qui a toujours du perdant
dans l'histoire
s'il était mis en oeuvre un tel accord
international conduirait à rendre
caduque le modèle de développement de
paradis fiscaux déclarations de gabriel
zucman économiste français et professeur
à l'université de berkeley olivier en
impôt mondial pour mettre fin aux
paradis fiscaux et déjà ce que je
comprends pas c'est que on n'est pas
réglé le problème des paradis fiscaux
pays par pays ou continent par continent
les états unis je vous le dis je vous le
dis je voulais dit plusieurs fois on le
dollar ware qui est une machine à
blanchir de l'argent et qui est un
paradis fiscal
vous avez en europe l'irlande l'irlande
il suffisait à un moment de lui dire bah
non terminée on l'a fait rentrer dans
l'europe on lui a collé ce modèle fiscal
sur sur le pays qui était je vous
rappelle un pays qui était une pauvre au
départ et on accole on a imposé ce
modèle fiscal en disant vous allez vous
développer comme ça et on l'a jamais
changé quand les banques irlandaises ont
sauté on est allé alors à leur aide mais
on a surtout conservé le même modèle
économique donc s'ils voulaient attendre
que les etats-unis se réveille là dessus
on aurait pu se réveiller il ya bien
longtemps nous mêmes sans attente que
monsieur biden
qui a été en plus un d un des
intervenants ou de la mer donc
se réveille ensuite jeudi à une chose
c'est tout de même c'est qu'à chaque
fois vous avez des des gouvernants qui
font de la bête et je vous le disais au
moment du début de ducobu donc je vous
le disais avant quand monsieur trump
avait baissé les impôts je vous disais
attention à chaque fois qu'un pays
s'endette la dette c'est de l'impôt
différé d'accord donc vous aurez une
augmentation des impôts l'on m'avait dit
mais non mais bien sûr que non regarde
trump n'arrête pas de les baisser
oui d'accord mais la mandature d'après
on les remet honte parce que il faut
bien payer tout ce que ces messieurs
distribuer à tour de bras tout le temps
et là ça va être la même chose en europe
c'est à dire que tout ce qui a été
dépensé
les oies deaver whatever it takes le
problème c'est qu'il ya toujours un
pigeon à la fin qui est là pour payer
donc vous aurez des augmentations
d'impôts dans tous les pays sauf qu'ils
ceux qui ont été bien gérées et donc
monsieur bailon essaie de récupérer
l'argent là où il peut c'est normal
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec nathalie jenson bonjour madame vous
êtes enseignant chercheur à neoma
business school bienvenue dans ces
caches merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
bon je risquais alors on va aller un peu
plus dans le détail avec vous nathalie
gens sont là dit la réforme de la
fiscalité internationale des entreprises
est en gestation depuis quelques années
maintenant l ocde un long chantier qui a
débuté par l'instauration d'un échange
automatique d'informations bancaires
entre pays coup d'accélérateur ces
dernières semaines avec la proposer la
proposition donc un de l'administration
byden leur première question globalement
est ce une bonne idée cet impôt minimum
une aimable mondiale selon vous et
pourquoi une bonne idée donc j'irai pas
je ne dirais pas que c'était une bonne
idée
je pense qu'elle est tout à fait
politiquement correct c'est à dire que
en effet comme l'a dit avant olivier
delamarche des états unis 100 ans qui
vont éventuellement ils vont devoir
augmenter les impôts et puis aussi parce
que le programme byden va plutôt dans ce
sens car ils essayent les coûts de faire
un plaidoyer pour pour faire en sorte
que tout le monde soit sur sur ce modèle
plutôt de hausse et donc pourquoi pas
envisager un taux mondial mais non c'est
pas une bonne idée du tout on était
plutôt arriver une situation
effectivement inverse puisque la l on y
arrive et où ça fait à peu près une
vingtaine d'années même trentaine
d'années maintenant que les taux au
niveau mondial sur les sociétés ont
plutôt tendance à baisser
d'ailleurs on est plutôt autour mondiale
en autour d'une vingtaine de 24% en
moyenne donc de toutes façons déjà le
premier constat c'est que si on a un
taux d'impôt minimum de 21
ça va pas changer grand chose dans la
moyenne ça va effectivement redistribuer
des cartes il va y avoir des perdants
comme il a été souligné puisque elle
vous avez des pays qui sont en dessous
vous avez voilà la suisse par exemple
est en dessous bon l'irlande comme on
l'a dit est en dessous maintenant il
faut pas oublier ce que des économistes
depuis longtemps en fait se discute
cette question du niveau de taux
d'imposition qui serait
le meilleur puisque de toute façon comme
le disait jean baptiste say en son temps
un impôt exagéré va détruire à la base
sur laquelle il porte donc en d'autres
termes si vous en vous augmentez la
fiscalité vous avez de fortes chances de
réduire en fait elle l'est les revenus
qui sur lesquels vont porter ce taux de
fiscalité en d'autres termes vous allez
découvrir et d'activités et c'est tout
le débat en fait de la fiscalité la
fiscalité
en effet si c'est un problème assez
complexe et penser qu'on va les résoudre
en mettant un tout mondiale uniforme
c'est vraiment c'est juste de la pure
politique est de la pure communication
on va regarder à présent la façon dont
pourrait se mettre en place cet impôt
c'est l'un des deux piliers de la
réforme fiscale sur laquelle on l'a dit
planches le cd eux il s'agit de taxer
les bénéfices d'une multinationale
selon la répartition à territoriale de
son chiffre d'affaires concrètement où
qu'ils soient localisés les profits de
multinationales feront l'objet d'un
impôt à minima mal an on parlait
initialement avec le cd ou d'un taux à
12 5% les etats-unis eux
elle souhaite proposer 21 % un taux qui
selon les ong réseau pour la justice
fixe elle l'a texte justice network peu
pourrait générer au moins 300 milliards
de dollars de revenus additionnels dans
le monde olivier c'est tout de même par
est pas rien en temps de crise ce n'est
pas rien en temps de crise le le je vous
dis le seul le seul souci c'est que si
vous voulez aujourd'hui le réflexe c'est
ont créé un problème parce que on gère
mal donc on crée un problème on met de
la dette et ensuite on s'aperçoit qu'il
faut les rembourser et donc pour la
romance et qu'est ce qu'on fait on
augmente les impôts donc c'est toujours
les a si on vise aussi avec ceux avec
c'est avec ces recettes récupérées pour
ça sert aussi pour financer un
gigantesque plan dans ses
infrastructures
donc c'est aussi de l'investissement
gigantesque plan de la structure les
investissements à chaque fois ça fait
des années qu'on nous sort que le la
dette est fait pour financer des
investissements c'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui la dette
par exemple en france elle est faite
pour pour
combler les dépenses courantes c'est à
dire les les les dépenses courantes
c'est comme si un ménage emprunter sur
dix ans à sa banque pour se nourrir pour
manger tous les jours ça ne peut pas
fonctionner d'accord donc arrêtons avec
ces histoires totalement délirante et
faisons ça au niveau déjà nationale
aujourd'hui vous avez des entreprises
qui échappe et on exprès en les faisant
passer en maintenant l'irlande dans
l'europe par exemple vous avez des
entreprises qui échappe complètement à
l'impôt qui ont un taux d'imposition qui
est à 8% vous prenez des sociétés du cac
vous avez un taux d'imposition sur leurs
activités mondiales qui est plus proche
de 7 8% que de 30
or toutes les entreprises qui sont des
pme et qui sont sur le sol national et
qui n'ont pas les moyens d'optimiser
fiscalement leurs leur leur fiscalité et
bien perdu 30%
donc il ya un moment où en effet on
pourrait peut-être réaligner un tout
petit peu les choses mais faisons le
déjà au niveau national que je sache
joe biden n'a pas été élu gouverneur du
monde
donc faisons-le eu déjà à notre échelle
ça sera déjà bien
l'intelligence soit une réaction oui de
toute façon c'est cette idée de vouloir
absolument harmoniser alors il dans la
fiscalité comme je le disais tout à
l'heure et c'est compliqué en fait la
réaction aux taux d'imposition
on sait pas parce qu'on va augmenter les
impôts quand fait les rentrées fiscales
vont augmenter puisque comme je le
disais précédemment ça décourage
l'activité n'avait tout simplement donc
donc il est il est trop simpliste de
penser qu'amd augmente au taux
d'imposition va faire rentrer plus
d'argent dans les caisses
bon là ce avait été évidemment
populariser cette idée par la fameuse
courbe la fameuse courbe d'arthur la
sphère kittin ou courbe en cloche qui
montrait que voilà il ya un taux au delà
duquel en fait finalement l'état rentre
moins d'argent
si par exemple il taxe à 100 % mais en
fait qu il
y'a pas beaucoup d'argent qui vont
rentrer dans ses caisses parce qu'en
fait ces trous et donc on va avoir sur
de l'activité non déclarée
soit on va sur voila on l'activité vont
fermer ils vont aller ailleurs
donc quand on dit qu'effectivement les
entreprises - et il est vrai que les
entreprises
évidemment multinationales ont cet
avantage ne pourra faire de
l'optimisation fiscale que les petites
entreprises ne peuvent pas faire ça
c'est indéniable maintenant le fait que
les multinationales en font finalement
peut aussi avoir des bénéfices des sur
les pays qui ont des taux d'intérêts
d'imposition plus élevé indirects alors
je m'explique pas ce que ça peut
paraître un peu paradoxal et et
peut-être contre intuitif mais si
effectivement vous fait plus d'activités
parce que vous est réussi réussissez à
faire de l'optimisation fiscale
finalement vous allez également
augmenter l'activité dans les pays où
vous ne payez pas vos impôts donc voilà
le fait que apple ne paye pas ses impôts
effectivement en france fait que fait
plus de profits que du coup ses
activités en france il va peut-être
davantage les développer en termes
d'effectifs donc si vous avez plus de
gens employés chez apple france c'est
bien ça fait quand même des rentrées
fiscales pour l'état français mais
effectivement c'est une rentrée fiscale
qui n'a rien à voir avec les bénéfices
d'apple mais qui à avoir en fait avec
les ventes supplémentaires d'apple de
fait qu'ils emploient des gens et qu'il
ya des cotisations sociales qui sont
payés voilà tout ça rend le système bien
plus compliqué est effectivement plutôt
que de plaider pour un taux d'imposition
minimal mondiale il faudrait aussi
plaidé pour une fiscalité beaucoup plus
transparents au niveau mondial parce que
comme il a été aussi évoquée par de la
marche en dehors du taux d'imposition où
il ya après toutes les niches que vous
trouvez et en général effectivement
quand on a un taux d'imposition faibles
en général on n'a pas beaucoup de niches
parce qu'on en a pas besoin
et quand on a des taux d'imposition
élevé on a plein de niche ce qui fait
qu'à la fin
finalement ce qu'ils peuvent utiliser
ces niches final on se retrouve à pas
payer d'impôts non plus merci à nathalie
jenson on va marquer une courte pause et
on revient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine l'un
pour mondiale voulue par joe biden et
pour cela nous sommes en liaison avec
nathalie gens sont enseignants
chercheurs à neoma business school
nathalie jenson a juste avant la coupure
pub au delà de faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses est ce qu'aujourd'hui
finalement l'enjeu c'est pas qu'une
multinationale paie en impôts là où elle
réalise son chiffre d'affaires est ce
que c'est pas aussi une question votre
justice fiscale oui j'entends bien cette
dimension de justice fiscale mais comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure
finalement la justice fiscale et pacy
aggravée dans la mesure où plus un pays
plus une entreprise va en fait va
optimiser fiscalement aujourd'hui du à 7
ce puzzle en fait de deux schémas
fiscaux différents entre les pays est
plus en fait elle va avoir une activité
florissante qui va avoir des retombées
positives même dans les pays où en fait
où la fiscalité est importante
puisqu'elle va continuer à développer
ses activités
donc de toute façon comme je le j'ai
essayé de montrer avec mon exemple tout
à l'heure de toute façon apple même
lorsqu'il sicile béni s'il a des
bénéfices en hausse et qu'il continue à
croître son activité en france
il y a des retombées positives pour la
france donc c'est bon on peut pas dire
qu'en fait ça n'a pas de retombées
positives pour la france le fait même
qu'il y est en effet une concurrence
fiscale et ça c'est souvent le point qui
est mal compris dans cette concurrence
fiscale
en fait elle n'est pas totalement
négatif puisqu'elle permet une expansion
d'activité qui elle crée génère en fait
des rentrées fiscales ou indirectement
aux états unis au vous êtes d'accord la
concurrence fiscale favorise une bonne
santé économique aussi oui alors je
modulerait peut-être un peu c'est à dire
que je pense que il ya vraiment il ya
vraiment quelquefois un décalage et puis
il ya ça dépend du modèle économique de
la de la société là vous avez choisi
apple
si je vous dis google ça va être tête
être un petit peu différent donc
puisqu'ils n'ont pas besoin du tout
d'engager des gens en france
ils peuvent le faire de d'ailleurs donc
mais mais il je suis d'accord avec le
mois l'analyse de départ qui était de
dire en fait c'est un coup de com il a
besoin lui de relever les impôts après
que trump les ait baissé et est en fait
c'est beaucoup plus facile de noyer le
poisson en parlant dans un beau mondial
pour faire passer une hausse des impôts
chez lui donc je pense que c'est plus
dans cette dans cette idée là que
réellement sachant qu'en plus vous avez
quand même un certain nombre d'états je
rappelle que bayonne n'a pas été élu
président du monde
que je sache déjà on n'est pas très sûrs
d'eux sort de sape de son élection aux
désunis mais en plus cela sur le coup
pour le coup il n'est pas pressé
hélas oui il a été élu il est président
des états unis
on est d'accord je dis simplement qu'il
ya eu des dd doute à un moment donc il
faudrait pas qu'il aille au delà de ce
que de ce que on lui a confié comme
mandat et aujourd'hui je doute que les
chinois je positionne propositions
censées par bon nombre de baies cette
proposition avait soutenu par bon nombre
de pays
oui mais vous avez des pays qui ne
seront pas d'accord pour le faire et des
grands pays
pas juste le liechtenstein et la suisse
donc vous aurez des pays qui ne joueront
pas le jeu et à ce moment là croyez-moi
les entreprises
on compte dans le dans ces pays
là donc il faut pas cesser c'est pas
simple je pense que ça serait plus
intelligent déjà de le faire au niveau
des pays au niveau des régions
si en europe on voulait vraiment le
faire on aurait pu supprimer ce modèle
économique à l'irlande depuis très
longtemps on aurait pu aussi ne pas
choisir monsieur juncker qui était qui a
été ministre au luxembourg pendant des
années et qui a organisé justement le
les fuites fiscales de pas mal de
sociétés comme président de la
commission européenne pendant des années
donc tout ça c'est c'est je vous dis
encore une fois de la com vous avez un
fait c'est que les états se sont
surendettés et sa pas simplement depuis
le coc vide mais depuis des années que
il faut payer et que la dette passée de
l'impôt différé donc on est en train de
s'apercevoir que quelqu'un va payer la
note et c'est no nathalie jenson a selon
le think tank américain tax foundation
le taux moyen donc vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure
d'imposition sur les sociétés est tombé
sous la barre des 24 % en 2020 alors
qu'il était de plus de 40 en 1981 alors
les impôts baisse et pourtant il ya
encore des tas d'entreprises 1 qui
pratiquent ce dumping fiscal
outre cet impôt à 10 mondial comment on
en vient comment comment venir à bout de
ce dumping fiscal mais en fait moi je
serais plutôt d'avis de deux mètres taux
d'imposition maximal comme ça au moins
on va mettre tout le monde d'accord et
on va simplifier le problème c'est à
dire qu'en fait si plus votre taux
d'imposition en feuilleté est faible et
moins vous avez évidemment d'incitation
à essayer de voir comment vous pouvez le
paigc et différemment ou moins de payer
ou pas le payer donc comme comme je le
rappelais
au départ il faut pas oublier que plus
le taux d'imposition est élevée et moins
on va avoir envie de le payer c'est à
dire que on a un problème de
consentement à la peau alors ce
consentement à l'impôt il est plus
compliqué a évidemment à à gérer quand
il s'agit de société parce que quand il
s'agit des des du taux d'imposition des
individus on voit bien que c'est pas
parce que dans 1 dans un pays d'ailleurs
on peut reprendre le cas de la suisse
qui lui est une c'est sûr des étages et
une confédération dont il ya bien
plusieurs niveaux d'imposition et c'est
pas pour ça que vous avez des des
cantons qui sont plus pauvres que
d'autres et même si on reprend l'exemple
de l'europe avec l'irlande c'est pas
parce qu'effectivement l'irlande après
ces modèles là qu'il est laid que la
france s'est totalement appauvri donc on
voit bien que c'est pas non plus parce
qu'on a un taux d'impôt qui est
supérieur que que l'activité va
s'évaporer tout d'un coup d'accord donc
ça c'est une heure c'est un fait
maintenant il est vrai que si on avait
quand même des systèmes fiscaux beaucoup
plus simple et beaucoup plus est clair
ça éviterait le cas statut fiscal ça
aussi permettrait peut-être une certaine
stabilité fiscale et donc ça permettrait
une plus grande lisibilité et sans doute
que les entreprises aient bien
embaucherait moins de gens qui serait
spécialisé dans comment tirer le
meilleur parti de cette constellation
fiscales constatées le tour de l'ain
merci beaucoup au natal et jenson
d'avoir été parmi nous dans sa reddition
je rappelle que vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à neoma business co les olives
et nous on continue avec les questions
cash
et on commence à olivier avec la
question de sandra si l'économie a
survécu à la crise de 2008 pourquoi ça
explosera avec celle ci n'êtes vous pas
un peu trop pessimistes comme d'habitude
monsieur de la marche non sans bras vous
savez ce que c'est qu'un pessimiste est
un optimiste bien informée donc non la
crise de 2008 en fait n'a jamais été
réglé et
c'est une première secousse d'un
tremblement de terre si vous voulez
c'est à dire que il ya une succession
après 2008 de deux secousses vous avez
2008 vous avez 2011
la crise grecque la crise de l'euro
ensuite vous avez monsieur draghi qui
arrivent et qui dit je sauverai même au
prix de ma mort je sauverai leroux et
les choses repartent et on met beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup de dettes et un jour
arrive le coc vide mais ça n'est qu'une
étape si vous voulez dans le délitement
de l'économie vous avez eu un choix à
faire en 2008 qui était l'économie
réelle où la finance les banques
centrales et les politiques ont choisi
la finance et donc que depuis il
s'applique gentiment à détruire
l'économie réelle et à booster la
finance donc pensez ce que vous voulez
sur le fait que je suis pessimiste ou
optimiste ou chefs d'entreprises donc et
chefs d'entreprise pessimiste ça
n'existe pas mais malheureusement je
regarde les faits et je vois une
économie qui se dégrade de jour en jour
au profit de marchés qui ne vont très
bien malheureusement ça une fin en face
à la question des deux chaînes mais la
bce pour soutenir la crise n'a fait que
créer de la monnaie
elle ne doit rien à personne je me
trompe personne n'a donc à rembourser ou
et la nécessité de rembourser vu que
tous les pays ont fait de même quel est
le but derrière ce refus d' effacer ses
dettes créées de toutes pièces une bête
je suis désolé le quand quentin états
s'endettent
je vous rappelle qu'ils aient l'état
c'est vous donc on vous en dette et et
on vous demandera aussi sûr que deux et
deux font quatre on vous demandera un
moment de rembourser
on vous apportera la note donc après
vous pouvez utiliser tous les différents
moyens vous pouvez faire un défaut sur
la dette
vous pouvez dire je ne vais pas
rembourser la dette vous pouvez dire on
va continuer comme ça et en faire de
plus en plus toutes ces méthodes
on le dirait le mérite d'exister mais
toutes ces méthodes ont des conséquences
malheureusement c'est à dire que si vous
décidez de continuer à imprimer des
billets en permanence eh bien vous
détruisez la monnaie vous détruisez la
valeur de la monnaie
si vous décidez un défaut de paiement et
bien évidemment vous allez fâché tous
ceux qui détiennent votre dette qui se
sont soit des étrangers soit vous même
vous vous en rendez même pas compte
malheureusement mais vous détenez de la
dette puisque si vous avez une assurance
vie ben c'est de la dette
si vous avez un produit bancaire quel
qu'il soit c'est de la dette
donc vous dites en bas il suffit de pas
la rembourser ok bah on vous rembourse
pas alors donc votre épargne disparaît
est ce que ça vous amuse
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine en
attendant pour voir ou revoir nos
précédentes émissions ça se passe sur
notre site internet à l'adresse rt
france pour un tv et puis n'oubliez pas
de poser toutes vos questions à olivier
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
rtk chez olivier on se quitte avec votre
dernier mot un problème un impôt